hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his unfinished work the posses Blaise
Pascal makes a very important and useful
distinction between two different
mindsets or you might say approaches to
life and thinking and reasoning that we
translate in English typically as the
mathematical mind or intellect in some
other places in the work and the
intuitive mind intuitive is not
necessarily the best translation but it
certainly has stock and there are a few
things that Pascal says that give you a
sense why the intuitive would be a term
that that translators would gravitate to
in French these terms are the sp2
geometry an display means mind but also
you could say mindset a spirit of course
is a cognate of it and the esprit de fée
Ness Pascal will also use in another
passage where he's talking about the sp2
geometry he will also talk about the sp2
Zeus tests and the idea behind juice
dash or finesse that gets us to
intuitive is that a person who has this
approach to things is able to sort of
see into matters and without necessarily
employing rules or regulations or
reasoning processes sort of feel their
way to the best solution to what is true
to what is just what is beautiful to
what is required within the situation
now I want to say from the beginning
that this is not supposed to be a
dichotomy where you look at it and you
say well am i this type of person or am
i this type of person Pascal says there
are some people who don't have either of
these and he calls those people what's
true
in English as weak minds and in the
French version of it the original
version is plea full meaning essentially
a mind that just cannot get to the truth
there are many people who lack either of
these basic dispositions or mindsets
it's also possible he says that a person
who has a mathematical mind or a
geometrical mind what we might call the
formal the axiomatic the mechanical mind
could in fact also have this plate of
finesse and likewise the person who has
the explain to finesse or the the
intuitive mind could in fact also have
to some degree the geometrical mind so
these are not diametrical opposites
these do not divide up humanity into
intuitive and mathematical let alone
left-brain right-brain people these are
two different you might say
dispositional skillsets and ways of
approaching reality both of which are
useful both of which in fact have their
place so how do they differ from each
other what is characteristic of each of
these you notice that in his discussion
of them Pascal is going to talk about
principles and that's just you know a
direct translation from the French you
know Pond seep meaning starting points
in the geometrical or the mathematical
mindset we begin from starting points
that are as he says palpable which means
that we can we can grasp them they are
right there in front of us much of the
time he says we're not actually
attending to them unless we are engaged
in a discipline such as geometry
geometry I should mention here does not
just mean the sort of thing that you
encounter in geometry class in middle
school high school college in geometry
textbooks it includes
everything that can be axiom at eyes
that can be given a mathematical
modelling everything that falls within
that province so it include a lot of
what we typically think of as going
beyond mere mathematics in geometry to
its application in real life including
technology and computers and coding and
things like that now he says the
principles that are being relied upon
that are being grasped by the
mathematical mind are removed from
common use they're not the sort of thing
that the average person in their
day-to-day life is typically
encountering and that's why the average
person is sort of out of their depth at
first at least at the beginning until
they get some experience and some
training under their belt when it comes
to these sorts of matters and so you
know think about a geometry class when
you first start studying mathematics
some things are very clear right if you
need one plus one equals two proven to
you you've got some problems but there's
a lot of other things in mathematics
where if you open up a mathematics or
geometry textbook you look at the
symbols and the notation of what the
hell is this about
right but then once you have the code
explained to you and you wrap your head
around the key concepts it all falls
into place
fairly easily and it's the same thing
with many other formal systems as well
which can in fact be modeled through
mathematics the principles he says when
we actually do look at them turn out to
be quite clear they turn out to be
understandable at least for the person
who's willing to apply him or herself
and the mathematical mindset uses those
principles and processes of reasoning
and definitions and axioms the the sort
of you know
reasoning processes that begin from
these clear starting points and you show
your work along the way and then you get
to the end and it makes sense and you
can sort of trace your way back that's
what in fact the mathematical mindset
looks like and it's like I said not just
a matter of mathematics
anything that you could formalize in
that way where adequate performance
would result from following the rules
following the reasoning process he's not
getting those sorts of things wrong
really fits into the mathematical
mindset now by contrast let's talk about
the intuitive mind or the esprit de fée
Ness when we we have an English cognate
term to finesse something right when you
finesse a relationship or you finesse a
negotiation or you are trying to break
into a place and you you use some
finesse to open up the the lock or
something like that what are you doing
you're kind of feeling your way to the
right solution to what makes the best
sense given those circumstances and in
this case Pascal says the principles are
found in common use the average person
could in fact have the intuitive mind
many don't of course like I said many
lack either of these according to Pascal
but the intuitive mind grasps these
principles in a way different than the
mathematical mind or different from the
ordinary person why because the
principles as he says are subtle he uses
other terms like fine they are somewhat
difficult to grasp sometimes it takes
some experience
sometimes it takes looking at it from
different points of view and thinking it
through we'll talk about some examples
but I just want to give you one right
now
when you think about tasting when you're
making a dish and you're cooking say a
sauce you taste from time to time you're
like you know I think that needs a
little bit more salt how much salt the
mathematician had asked a - now a - of
course that's a matter of finesse that's
not a matter of mathematics you know a
pinch how much is a pinch the
mathematical mind would say well you
know about this much and then you taste
it some more that's a little bit too
much maybe we need to add something now
to balance out the salt like a tiny
little bit of sugar or perhaps a bit of
vinegar to add some sourness to it
that's what the Esprit to finesse is
doing they're working with many
different things all of which are play
in play at the same time and they're in
some way processing all of this and
balancing it all out and taking account
of the entire idea so the principles as
he says are subtle and they are many
they are multiple their numerous is is
the way the translation goes some of
them actually need as he says to be felt
rather than seen and here we can
understand felt as not you know
necessarily feeling with the fingers but
felt as in sensing effectively having a
grasp on it rather than just like
looking at the numbers looking at at
what's provided to you you have to have
a sense as we say or an intuitive grasp
this is why it gets translated as the
intuitive mind what else the person who
has the esprit de finesse takes in these
principles as Paschal says in one glance
it's not that they don't do any
reasoning but they're not showing their
work they're not doing so in a way that
other people would easily be able to
follow along or they would easily be
able to express and articulate either to
themselves or to somebody else as a
matter of
when you combine the two of these you
get something very very powerful which
is an intuitive mind that is able to
express itself in ways that can then be
learned by another person but that takes
a lot of work so they taken these
principles at one glance and as Paschal
says it's very important that they take
in all of the principles because if you
leave one of them out things can go
haywire and this is why people who are
so used to sort of a mathematical
geometric rules based approach to things
do so poorly when it comes to
enterprises and activities and projects
that really require the intuitive mind
because they say well I I did all the
things I was supposed to do and you're
like well in this case you left this out
and this turns out to be quite important
well I didn't know I was supposed to
look at that well you know I wish you
would have seen that in this case I wish
you would have checked in with me
because then I could have said attend to
this principle over here of course the
intuitive mind person is not going to
generally talk in terms of principles
but they'll say well have you thought
about this or hey what about that now
with that basic distinction down can we
think of examples of activities besides
of course mathematics that would fall
under this think about how to bake a
cake right baking and pastry is actually
compared to other forms of cooking very
precise in some respects you could say
that it fits the mathematical mind a bit
better than say making sauces or cooking
a roast or barbecuing barbecuing is very
much when you do it well a matter of the
intuitive mind how much longer is does
it need to smoke I'll know when I get
there if that's the intuitive mind
talking it
how good of course if it turns out bad
then you've got you know one of those
weak minds that that Pascal was talking
about so you know we can we can talk in
terms of cuisine we can talk in terms of
tasting and connoisseur ship we can also
talk in terms of product development
product development I think is in large
part a matter of the mathematical mind
how much sugar how much corn syrup
should we add to this you know really
the answer for corn syrup is none but a
lot of a lot of the things that we eat
that it's processed foods have a lot of
that in there and that comes from
ignoring very important facets that
would be left out and that the intuitive
mind would grasp
you know these principles like well the
food actually needs to taste good not
just like every other thing that's made
with corn syrup falling in love and not
screwing it up definitely a matter of
the intuitive mind right
giving psychological advice in some
respects it could be made a matter of
the mathematical mind think about
cognitive behavioral therapy and some of
the protocols that they've developed and
the treatment plan you know formulas and
templates some of these things can in
fact be understood and in very
mathematical ways how to deal with this
particular client who has trauma in this
way how many sessions is it going to
require that might actually be a
decision made much better by somebody
who has the intuitive approach what to
say at the right time what is going to
be the you might say liberation airy
thing the interpretation to offer to the
clients there's no rules for that so
this is a very important to stick
distinction pascal's has a few other
things that I wanted to mention here he
says that that the intuitive minds are
astonished when they're presented with
propositions of which they understand
nothing
and the way to which is through
definitions and axioms so sterile and
which they are not accustomed to see in
detail that there they are repelled and
disheartened so there is a kind of
incomprehension that can happen with
people who are very much in this mindset
when it comes to the mathematical mind
that wants to know well how are you
actually proving this or what are what
are your steps on the way or why did you
make decisions this way and when it
comes to understanding these things is
why a lot of people say I just don't get
math it's not that they don't get math
if they put in the work and the effort
they would get the math but that's
harder for the intuitive mind because
it's accustomed to doing things in a
different way likewise the mathematical
mind when it's it's sort of over
developed and underdeveloped in this
area has a very hard time figuring out
what the hell this person is doing how
did they arrive at this decision what's
going on here it seems very messy very
arbitrary very here's one of the words
subjective right and there is a sort of
distrust on both sides
sometimes paschal however wants to make
the case that if you are in either of
these mindsets you would really be
strengthened by taking up the other side
and understanding it
so he says mathematicians who are only
mathematicians have exact minds provided
all things are explained to them by
means of definitions and axioms
otherwise they're inaccurate and
insufferable they're only right when the
principles are quite clear men of
intuition who are only intuitive cannot
have the patience to reach the first
principles of things speculative and
conceptual which they've never seen in
the world these are pits that they can
fall into however if they do in fact
learn the the language the mindset of
the other side they
a greater potential for getting to the
truth of things so that is this
fundamental distinction Paschal doesn't
have a few other things to say about it
in other of his thoughts but that is
encapsulated how he treats it in the
fragment that is entitled the
mathematical mind and the intuitive mind
you